air france vient de prendre livraison de
deux boeing 747 qui sont actuellement
pensionnés à orly le jeune thomas s'est
intéressé à ce monstre le plus gros
appareil commercial en service de nos
jours mais il devra attendre le 4 juin
prochain pour effectuer le premier vol
sur l'atlantique nord
c'est en compagnie de trois cent
soixante autres passagers qu'il
effectuera la liaison paris états unis à
la vitesse le 950 km heure dans cette
immense hangar aménagé par aéroports de
paris le boeing 747 reçoit en ce moment
même son équipement et sa décoration
intérieure avec 71 mètres de long il a
vraiment l'air petit sous les voûtes de
cette cathédrale métallique de 200
mètres de longueur pour notre petit
bonhomme la carlingue encore vides et
bien entendu impressionnant la version
retenue par air france et de 36
passagers en première classe et 324 en
classe économique
thomas a l'air d'apprécier le confort
des sièges tout est prévu que d'ailleurs
pour que les voyageurs soit agréablement
servi treize toilettes un bar salon
situe à l'arrière du poste de pilotage
une épaisse moquette recouvrira la
structure du sol
voilà on est installé pour le grand
départ
un troisième 747 celui de la têt w a
inauguré aujourd'hui son premier vol sur
les etats-unis et ce matin même c'est
zizi jeanmaire qu'il la baptisait c'est
tout naturel puisqu'il s'appelle star of
parisse le même nom que portait il ya 24
ans le constellation de cette compagnie
qui fit la liaison paris new york